Il y a au fond de mon jardin
un bac à compost.
Je vous en parle aujourd'hui pas uniquement parce que c'est le deuxième jour de confinement,
mais parce que c'est
la journée internationale du recyclage.
Depuis des années, j'y dépose mes déchets verts,
les épluchures, le marc de café, les essuie-tout...
alors c'est vrai qu'en surface, c'est pas très ragoûtant.
Mais après plusieurs mois de confinement,
quand les micro organismes ont dégradé les déchets,
eh bien on obtient une matière recyclée,
très agréable au toucher.
Je vais l'utiliser pour enrichir
le sol de mon petit jardin.
Et en plus, ça sent le sous-bois.
Une vraie "capsule de déconfiné".
Allez ! à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés, mais on reste en lien.
Même formule qu'hier, je recycle.
Si vous avez aimé cette
"capsule de déconfiné",
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque
jour, alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous... et à demain !